[Musica]
ti ringrazio step per questa partenza
incredibile ok basta il video può
concludersi qua per quanto riguarda due
sparano del cecchino e le video devono
completare un percorso senza siamo
attratti dal circolo g qui entriamo e
decide lui chi fa il cecchino
ok decidi tu decidi tu ti prego fammi
fare il cecchino che voglio sparare a
bere le tasse
quelli che non completare il percorso
hanno solo tre vite a destra ok hanno
quindi no no sai ascolta me ti ascolto
vai guardati che l'essere questa mappa
prima di tutto dobbiamo correre così
loro sono alla nostra destra se ti
affacci un po'di dovresti vedere se un
tipo sopra una lampada giganti sorella
pietro dobbiamo sfruttare le coperture a
cerca di utilizzare i divani per le cose
per capire ma si senta guidarli mai
aiuto specialmente perché non ti copre
il dibatto fiuto no ragazzi non è
impossibile ma doveva avere la porta
alla volta ti copro porta di casa la via
deve avere spento senza stata indotta va
detto aspetta solo film della marvel
aiuto carcere non mi sta prendendo e
scarso quell'altro aiuto allora non è
così facile
questi coprono no cosi cosi coprono
coprono propria una malavita adesso che
facciamo di posina mandiamo balletto
perfetto ragazzi io mister proietti
l'impact terreni madonna lega chiama no
ma no dai
ma 15 tiri generi per provare quante
volte vuoi che entra niente giusto
giusto micore colorful ed io continuo a
correre così iniziano a puntare a me che
sono più avanti e renault sono molto qua
prima però hai fatto uccidermi one shot
perché gli avevano dato il pid
all'inizio per quello che viene
ammazzato 66 sarebbe il più possibile
vai vai corri corri aiuto aiuto
mamma mia che kakà
no ragazzi 9 jacchia male sono toccati
in amati fa risorgere secondo il suo
punto eserciti con la cera accetto anche
lì si avrebbero per ricaricare per come
faccio a seguirla sopra non correre
madonna reaganiano è difficilissimo va
dai lavori vedermi tof ora che è
impossibile allora li distrae che
ricorrere ci sto provando un macello
io sono quasi al terzo diventerà di
sparare sono me non è facile non è fatto
dalla rega incredibile difficilissima
sull'ansia perfetto effetto che d'altro
prima mi spaccate poi dopo non riuscite
più a colpirmi non so per certo perché è
difficilissimo veniva un po
voglio vedere dopo sono state mai
corridori bari ma io non ce l'ho fatta
aspetto non credo che non ci ha fatto sì
quasi ok non farei mai un livello senza
moglie e dai corridori home io fuori
cosa hai a chiamare a che titolo ucciso
già fatta e ho vinto quindi che
aspettarmi dice una cosa bella da far al
chelsea non ha letto non li stanno
puntando veramente però si e perché no
io faccio io a dare supporto questo
così ti prego sbrigatevi spara
parliamone per favore per ora non ci
sono e hanno ucciso tema come fatto
ovviamente i ninja solo quando non serve
scusa se riesco uccidere ho fatto arrivo
vinto
non credo si aspetta no no no no no non
è moroso gli aggiornamenti due hub e
chissenefrega va bene cosi poche io sono
un cecchina mento quando volete ragazzi
miei ma questo forse potrebbe essere
molti e ragazzi è indietro e fare
attenzione mio ragazzo era la porta non
è bucata purtroppo aste lungo brita lui
proprie draw miu miu quanta fortuna ha
avuto non lo sai mai che sfiga mai
arrivati ok ok ok ci sono in più di più
chiaro piano beh lasciamo lì da almeno
lì mellino li abbiamo fatto fare ma
credo che se ci fosse ninja la nuova
queste morti istantaneamente finisci
livello almeno noi oggi credit e pietro
ha ucciso tre volte in feriti di fare
due livelli da sola con una vita sola
praticamente
by cioè no non si porta non si porta di
nuovo
continua la moria mamma mia è veramente
siete accanire che vi farà allora non
scordo dai ragazzi possibile lo scopo
impossibile eventi possibile non so non
l'ho presa ci pensi se ci arriva a suo
tempo non senti adesso sto morendo
d'ansia perchè fu girato a mamma mia
gigi gigi mi metto 6 kills 6 perché ci
siamo ci siamo ragazzi ci sia mai io e
pietro contro steve fair e vieni qua
allora seguimi che questa materia di che
che son forti loro e fanno le cose
giuste
allora vai prima tutti noi non votato
non ci sentono verso l'infinito non vale
non corri stavolta è bucata non usare
dietro corri aiace male al cecchino
pagato e chi non pagato devo dire il suo
zio che ansia aiuti usa come schiuma
coloro che si sono arrivato
se no te primo aspetta aspetta ac
credimi che risalto che il fucile parti
che sono incasinati parti pietro reparti
9 st che voleva beve parti non hai mai
letto perfetto perfetto che non ho
solamente rifare continuazione secondo
me ne stavo ballando
aiuto aiuto fatta carica
si no tutti insieme anche gli effetti
sonori aliena prego vai maledizione
ighalo aperitivi e freddi mila paia
fatta l'ultima luce negativa che non si
crede attenzione attenzione pietro
chiara di cosa fai
domani la gara di mario sembrano
percorrere ma cerchi da parte di sopra
non l'ho vista perfetto allora bene bene
è finita qui abbiamo altri pieni pietro
che ti aiuto vieni vieni qua ne prendo
l'altro dai maya o devi riuscire
ucciderti che se non abbiamo in carica
lida e buoni due madonne con casini con
casini non lo so veramente guidare
questo affare
non so guidare ma ancora macchina è
possibile mio dio mio dio che pirla no
hanno preso loro dai normale l'haka male
e che vale che vuole anzi molte volte
rimane l'ultima copia sono ma perché non
prendo c'è point e riparto di qua pietro
sparagli cosa non è facile come sias per
le pagine aiuta non è facile come sia
per le pagine
tutto perché vincono quelle va dai
confini tra ragazzi tu però sta
benissimo
va bene basta per me si può concludere
qui è stato veramente figo
niente ragazzi è finita qua ci vediamo
al prossimo video ringrazio pietro
ringrazi su place non consola la chicane
alinghi entrambi descrizione e noi ci
vediamo come sempre al prossimo vita da
ragazzo
[Musica]